and you know
pam's having technical difficulties
you're ready to it's time to go if
all right uh we'll uh start with the
uh work session on free edna
um and then we will be moving into
executive session
um as chair of the house executive
department's administration committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor
as a result of the covert 19 pandemic in
accordance with the governor's emergency
order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a full committee work session on
bills referred to the executive
department's administration committee it
will be followed by
an executive session please note there
is no
physical location to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this
meeting which was authorized pursuant to
the governor's emergency order
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that we are
a providing public access to the meeting
by telephone
with additional access possibilities by
video or other electric
means we are utilizing zoom for this
electronic meeting
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through this platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in the
meeting by clicking on the following
website address
https colon forward slash forward slash
doom dot u s forward slash j forward
slash
nine five five two nine five seven
nine six or dialing one of the following
phone numbers
one three zero one seven one five
eight five nine two or one
nine two nine two zero five
six zero nine nine b by by friday
public notice of the necessary
information for accessing the meeting
we previously gave notice to the public
of the necessary information
for accessing the meeting including how
to access the meeting using zoom
or telephonically this information is
printed in the house calendar
c providing a mechanism for the public
to alert the public party during the
meeting if there are problems with
access
603-271-3600
or email at hcs
leg.state dot nh
dot u s d adjourning the meeting if the
public is unable to access the meeting
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled i want to
introduce
the staff that are on the meeting
assisting us pm smiling is the meeting
host
additional staff providing support our
gen 4 and joel anderson
this is a work session on bills referred
to the edna committee for interim study
an exec
executive session will follow copies of
the interim study bills have been posted
on the main page of the general court
website
under the heading remote meetings
please note that all votes that are
taken during the meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
uh let's start the meeting by taking the
roll call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
and representative scientific if you
want to call the role
representative show it people have to
unmute
sorry john i am present at home and
alone
okay representative judy
representative schmidt i am home alone
home alone representative schultz
present my husband will be in and out of
the room
as are my pets
going twice representative fontenot
representative desjardins present
and in my den alone
representative fellows present alone
representative fox president and i am at
my house alone
representative grota president at home
alone in my office but my husband is
home
representative merchant president
at home my wife and daughter may be in
and out
one more time representative pimentel
he is not i'll be that way
representative mcguire
um cur currently alone
is in the house uh the clerk is alone
and is here somewhere representative
bowden
is representative bowden again no
representative prue is not here
representative panic city
i am here i'm here
if you say so uh representative pearson
i'm in my home in east area and despite
my background
and um my wife is present in the house
not feeling well representative
yakubovic
president of the house alone
representative melvin is filling in for
representative byrd i believe
representative melvin yeah
home alone okay and representative
o'brien is here for representative
pimentel
and would you repeat please
i'm sorry yes representative brian
o'brien is home alone
uh mary ask please to repeat who is in
representatives
oh sure okay i'm sorry i got it thank
you
and the chair is present where is he
okay 16 members present uh we will begin
um pam could someone just reach out to
representative fontenot he said he was
going to be on i just want to make sure
he's not having trouble
all right um as you all know
due to the covert 19 and the
circumstances
uh there was limited abilities to
it's our job today when we go into
executive session to determine whether
they
are needed to go forward with future
legislation
or not recommended for future
legislation on on
so just to
move forward um before we exec them
uh we can go through each bill
individually briefly
and um go from there
into executive session and vote on these
um
on interim study bills for those of you
who are not familiar
when we do exec them for recommended for
future legislation are not recommended
for future legislation
from the committee on how we determine
from there there are no minority reports
we do not vote on them as a full house
they are just printed in the calendar on
the recommendations of the committee on
each of these bills
does anyone have any questions on the
process first
representative schmidt has his hand up
representative schmidt
just to clarify representative fontenot
sent us a message
saying that he is detained by a property
management issue and will not be with us
today okay
oh okay well that answers that no
and mr chairman can i just remind
members that their
raise hand button is at the bottom of
the participant panel
or if they're on the phone it's star
nine to raise your hand
uh so we can
start uh we'll start with house bill
1367.
and open that up for discussion amongst
the committees
on this um i know when we talked there
was a number of areas that needed work
and that was the reason why we did
interim study to look forward to see if
there was
any work that couldn't be done on this
going forward
or if we thought it was needed
[Music]
representative mcguire mcguire yes thank
you
uh i looked into this i asked
represent ms smarling to do
get some data and it appears
that in many cases we don't have an
issue but there are a number
of professions where we license them
[Music]
and other states don't
and one thing that we that i think is
that
this does need future legislation
but a more
focused bill would be much more
appropriate
that we we look at each profession any
profession that we think has an
issue and decide what to do about it
these broad ones broad bills that say
are are very awkward to deal with
in a fight if i remember looking at the
document
that pam did for us there wasn't a lot
of states
i mean a lot of licensing that we only
had we were the only state
or one of the handful of states there
was
not that many correct yeah yes there
were three on her list
and all three three of those professions
it have requirements such that it'll be
easy for somebody
from out of state to do the same thing
as somebody from in-state
like a waymaster they have to take a
test every time they get a new license
so you know you move to the state you
take the same test everybody else does
and then apply for the license uh
but she pam only looked at the
non-medical professions
so there that's of concern particularly
as we're adding new
medical imaging technicians are not
licensed in any of the adjacent states
but there are there they do have them
and we all and that's one that i think
we particularly ought to look at what
so would we need this
legislation going forward are we looking
at something different because we're
just looking at
yes instead of recommending future
legislation that we want
to i'm not sure how we want to work it's
not recommended for this one but we
those ones that are similar yes
the bill raises important issues and
legislation is needed to address them
but
this bill itself i can't see being the
way to go
further discussion from the committee on
this
representative
yeah i was representative okay
yeah thanks i was just going to point
out basically what you just said jeff
um and i i will point out that whether
we
recommend or not the statement that we
put up
can say basically what carol just
suggested
to me it seems more proper to say
i'm not recommended on this particular
bill
but as long as you're pointing out that
perhaps legislation specifying certain
professions is pointed out in the
statement
i think that's going to accomplish what
what
who else do we have pam uh
representative schmidt has his hand up
you need to there you go okay yeah i'm
good
so i agree with representative mcguire
that
this is not the right bill but but the
issue does remain
so uh i'm in in agreement with her
proposal and uh
well
yeah i uh we're dancing around a
particular issue
or a question and that's when you say
when we recommend for future legislation
are we aren't necessarily saying this
bill but rather this subject matter
and i you know i think that the subject
matter needs to go
forward if not this bill so i
i i think we we basically agree
but i want to be am i clear i get
my focused question recommended for
further
future legislation further legislation
does that mean area or this specific
bill
pm i think it all comes out can you
correct me if i'm wrong in the general
wording
when we put it forward is that not true
it's not
it doesn't always have to be the
particular bill itself but
it can be the subject matter it's all in
the wording of the blurb or committing
report
that's correct that you know you really
could
you know pick either option and as long
as you're clear in your
statement exactly what you're
supporting whether you you know then
that's
really the you know final
explanation of what you're doing you
know
okay it's up to you how you want to how
defined you want to
you know speak about the particular
language of this bill if you want to
think of it as the particular language
then that would be very narrow but it's
it's generally considered
a concept in the bill and whether you
are supportive of
further work and a new news in a new
session
okay yeah this is reflective of the
committee today and we cannot bind any
future legislate
legislature to our decision so i mean
this is just
a
seeing none we'll move over to
um we did have a subcommittee on this
representative prove chair that he is
not here today
uh representing panda city i think you
were also on there
i was you want to give us a little
insight on this yeah if i can
remember correctly i um did have um
several committee meetings regarding it
and
we were all in favor of the concept of
surveillance cameras but there was
um there was issues with placements
um and and privacy
issues um we thought
and i and i want to i don't know if this
is
pam do you remember if there was an
amendment to this
we did did steve did mark draft an
amendment to this thing i can't remember
if if he did he didn't put it in the
file there was an amendment from
prior to your hearing but not you know
no other amendment that came in after
the subcommittee worked on it so
um well i know i know that we both
kind of agreed that it was a good thing
we we listened to some
uh some individuals that came in that uh
were all for this thing because i think
somebody got uh roughed up pretty badly
and they thought
having cameras would would uh be the
answer but
then it became the privacy issue because
the cameras could only be in certain
areas
and not be in certain areas so we
thought
i believe we agreed that it would
probably be best to go forward
and um continue discussing we thought it
was a good idea but
i thought there were issues so
it was impending city was there also
there was also wasn't there an issue
as to cost as well those are the two
problems
there was an issue of cost but we didn't
have anybody that came in and said
specifically how much it would cost to
put in
put in uh recording systems or any of
that it was all
uh kind of assumptions of it would be
an expense even even a small expense
some of these
some of these halfway homes or homes uh
couldn't afford it uh they couldn't
afford any expense
whether it was hundreds of dollars or
thousands of dollars they didn't think
it was
um they could afford that
so that was that was kind of uh coming
from the home side but they also said it
would be a pretty good idea to have them
but they didn't know how it was going to
be made for that's why we thought
maybe we should have further discussion
okay i i also agree with that i think
it's uh worth moving forward on this
um but obviously the privacy issues need
to be addressed as well as the cost
issues
um but i think you know this isn't a bad
further discussion i see
representative schultz has her hand up
next representative
i was just trying to lower it but i
guess it bears mentioning that
i was going to say exactly what
representative panda city said
write that down america see we can agree
so then representative schmidt has his
hand up representative schmidt
thank you mr chairman um i second the
remarks that have been offered thus far
i think it just needs to be factored
into our
discussion that the pandemic
has uh has wreaked additional
uh hardship uh imposed additional
burdens on
uh the affected community here
so that's something we have to make sure
that the
uh that is considered in the legislation
but i
support the position in support of the
bill
that's been uh offered by a number of
colleagues
you know the discussion mr chairman i
don't know
what your feeling is about attendees
participating but there is a hand up
in the among the attendees sarah aiken
from community bridges
all right you should be able to
hi thank you very much chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is sarah akin and i represent
community bridges we're one of 10 area
agencies that serve people with
developmental disabilities and acquired
brain disorders in new hampshire
i wanted to let you know we have been
working on this issue
with the department of health and human
services for some time
and i believe the issue has been
resolved
in that there is a process in place now
it is in rule that allows for
um surveillance cameras to be used
at the request of the individual the
parent or the guardian
there is a process for it and i'm happy
to send you the rule
um if you're interested
but i believe that this has been solved
um like i said it is in hem
309 and it'll
if necessary so the it allows for it but
it does not place the financial burden
and it does not put as many of you
remember
during our previous discussion we talked
about
how there is a federal settings rule
that this bill as written would
put all of the wait list
funds for people with disabilities in
jeopardy
so that is that is was our very
significant concern so at the request
of the subcommittee we did go back and
work with the department and there is a
process now in place
so i just wanted to inform you of that
um please be cognizant
we're talking hundreds of millions of
dollars at risk
from the federal government um and there
is now a process in place
with that i will end my comment and i
thank you for your time
thank you for that information um and
just for those folks that are out there
and so they know that
as we talked about the beginning of this
meeting that this does not
pass the legislation this does not
guarantee it's going forward that's all
it is is a recommendation from this
committee as to whether or not
future legislation should be brought
forward in the subject matter
not this particular piece um
so while there is something in rules you
know it does not stop us from going
forward with the concept
and addressing the issues we've
discussed here today dealing with cost
and
privacy as well but thank you for
letting us know so that we can uh look
that up and if you could get that to us
the host will be informed anyone else
pam
uh representative has his hand up
representative yeah before
representative
uh schmidt or mcguire
say this can this be done by rule
i don't see why not that won't stop
i mean the question is if they if an
age if a house
wants to install cameras for their
staff security or whatever they can do
that with and the rules would establish
what the criteria are or
what the limitations would be uh
if they want to start if you want to
have
cameras all over the place in every
house that doesn't particularly want it
if i may continue was it the point of
the legislation that these would be
required everywhere
uh what's the point if uh
there is an issue of abuse in a
particular house that doesn't have a
camera
what good's the law what's good what are
good
what good are the rules if it doesn't
representative schmidt would you like to
comment
well it is a bit of a conundrum i agree
with what representative mcguire
said uh but of course one of the
primary uh criteria and one of the
primary
motivating issues was the question of
abuse of residents of these homes
obviously to the degree that an
individual family wants to
have their loved ones uh
uh a room surveilled
uh that that's probably true but i think
one of the thrusts is
to be able to protect uh inmates
uh residents and so forth
and so i think that you would require a
law
to do to provide that foundation
um and and so i don't i don't think you
representative thank you um
i think that recommending this although
it's great to know that
that there are things that are happening
in the right direction
there are those people who can't speak
for themselves
and who don't have advocates
and i think that it's important to
consider them
and i think that recommending this for
yes is just saying that this this this
committee agrees that this is a good
thing and
it is worth something it is valuable
so i i do think that still we should
consider continuing
thank you any further discussion
representative merchant has his hand up
represent a merchant
if i miss the chair go back to the
original question about
rules versus the law rules really have
the
full force of the law behind it it's
just a question where it emanates from
the legislative body versus the
executive branch
through rulemaking granted to the
executive branch from
legislative branch so in essence if the
department decides to make a rule to
make the same requirement
that would have the same impact as the
law requiring it itself
so to be clear of everyone this could in
my opinion be done through rulemaking
as long as the rule says the same thing
the law would have said
uh so with respect i disagree
um to the the course representative
merchant is correct that the rules do
have the force and effect of law
but they have to be based on they are
rules are there to implement statutes
they are not there to deal with
situations which
in which the statutes are silent
so to the degree that we wish to
to impose this requirement
we would have to have a statute to
underpin it
but i would like to just reference the
remarks of
miss aiken earlier with regard to the
jeopardizing of
uh federal funding we would have to
um we have to have more information of
course any statute
that would be you know any bill that
would come forward
would have uh have to go through that
entire process so
but we we have to earmark the whole
situation as i would say
um with regard to the
potential jeopardizing of the
representative mcguire actually
peter said it just just fine i agree
with them
thank you any other hands pin
no other hands all right
very quick how does sarah aiken spell
s-a-a-r-a-h
a-i-a-e-n
establishing committee to study salaries
of classified unclassified state
employees and directing the department
of administrative services
to issue a request for proposal to
conduct a study
we'll start first by saying we all
receive
some research that pam did on this and
where they are
at this point with their study and funds
and going forward um
hopefully everyone received that
that went out it did not actually go out
with the bills and
minutes but i sent it out when i sent
notice about the zoom meeting and the
agenda and the the list of the
the four interim study bills so that
pam do you just want to go over briefly
where they're at with that
in your review for everybody for those
who don't
have it in front of them um we
i had asked the question in in august to
get an update on what had happened with
the
rfp that the department of
administrative services
had put out and deputy commissioner
keane
got back to me and
she said that on march 11th of this year
the governor and council approved a
contract
for siegel to perform a two-part
compensation study and and they were two
two areas of the the state employee sort
of
compensation world that had been
included
in um a chapter law in
house bill 4 actually from 2019
and one was reallocation review of
all the trooper positions and the second
part was a comprehensive review
of the state's personnel system which is
what this
bill more or less contemplates
was signed in march and
they the first part was completed um
but not the second part because of covid
and so it is
that second part of the the
comprehensive review of the personnel
system study is still there it's still
funded but it has it's on hold right now
but the uh the contract does have an end
date of march 11
2022. um so she
felt that once
people were back in a more traditional
routine
um that would happen you know they're
poised to
thank you uh does anyone have any
questions
comments i see hands i see
representative pearson and schuett
pearson yeah the
the action that was just described
that's
that's funded by the that already
happened through the governor's office
does that in essence do the same thing
that 1528 does or is there
additional things within this that are
not covered under what was
pam if i could i think i saw
representative walls in attendance
oh when i see her as luck would have it
her she's got her hand up excellent
could you unmute her
sure sure representative walls welcome
thank you um i did raise my hand because
i can answer that and the answer is is
that
the study that they have sent the
contract out on
and what i intend in this bill are in
fact the same thing
so like anybody i'm disappointed the
study is proceeding slowly i thought
that it might
among other things even help with the
current contract pending
uh for the poor state employees who
don't have a contract but i think at
this point like everything else
uncovered we're just gonna have to wait
so i think that the contract's been let
given how long it is before they have to
complete the contract that it's really
another 18 months
at this point i don't see a point in
further legislation
i think if there's a problem with it we
can do legislation in the second year of
the session
but i think for right now uh probably i
would
uh i'm not on the committee but i would
recommend the committee not
pursue further legislation okay
thank you thank you thank you
and representative schuett has a hand up
representative
you um it's actually going to
sort of say the opposite uh as a
co-sponsor on this bill
but um i will follow the lead of
my prime sponsor representative walls
and agree that if she feels that it's
not necessary to go forward now
that she or i are re-elected
we could put a bill in in the second
half of the
biennium to cover this
dude uh representative walsh has her
hand up again
um i just are interested in why
representative schuett disagrees what is
it she knows that i don't know
so that's why i put my hand up
um well i i will just point out to you
representative walls that the main
reason that we put this bill
into inner study was to
sort of be sure to
hold the department of administrative
services feet
with the fire if you will to be sure
that they
are going to go forward with this
currently i
understand the rfp that's been approved
only cover a few hundred positions
and we want to be sure that they are in
fact going to
continue on and look at the whole
spectrum
am i unmuted can you hear me you are
um okay if i could just say one thing
first um i think the point being that
even if we do this
as not recommended for future
legislation the way we word it
can clearly state what representative
walls wants it as she has suggested
that if it um while this is going
forward this legislation is not needed
but in a time certain in the next
biennium if it is not completed we can
move forward that would be recommended
and representative walls um when i
talked to the department of
administrative services
and they they actually talked to them
the day they put the rfp out
they told me at that point that it was
going to encompass both all classified
and unclassified employees
um i have not seen the the rfp or the
contract to know in fact if that's what
they did
but i think that any recommendation for
the committee needs to
be cleared that that is the intent of
what the commit i'm assuming what the
committee wants as well
judging by representative schuett's nods
and and the original bill is it was
was to encompass all classified and
unclassified employees
and unfortunately i did not see i was
not on pam's distribution list so i'm
not sure what she put out
but um you know i think that that is
worth following through on and making
sure that the rfp
is consistent with what they told me at
the time
thank you any uh there are
discussion any hands up i would just ask
if
if uh mr chair if you want pam to
clarify the um terms of the
pam what i included in the memo is
exactly
like verbatim what i was given by the
assistant commissioner the deputy
commissioner i forget
deputy commissioner and and that was
that eagle would would perform a wage
and benefit study of 100 classified and
unclassified positions and i didn't
how those positions were chosen or
anything like that so i i don't know
more than
than what's included there
mr chairman if i may uh this is bringing
up something the depths of my memory
that they do not in fact look at all
positions but that they
sample at all levels and perhaps that's
why they're talking about only a hundred
right now
is that they're doing sampling and then
they will base their study on the
sampling
as i think about this i remember that
discussion as well
okay and i i would assume if we did all
i suspect you're right
further discussion uh
so i just asked as prime sponsor
representative walls you would be
satisfied with
those terms well if the sampling crosses
the spectrum of all classified and
unclassified employees yes
i just you know i'm assuming that that
what they told me is what they're doing
and what's in the contract
i have no reason to doubt it so assuming
that's what they did with their sampling
i think it's just fine
okay i would rather add that
i did reach out to jay ward
representative from mca testified on the
build
and he said that the
sca was satisfied with
the rfp that was approved by governor
and council
uh but obviously they haven't been able
to follow
where they're going with it at ex
moments so
i'm assuming that they will also follow
through to be sure that
and that can be in the report that we
put forward
one way or the other looking forward
i see no hands we will
move on to our final bill
uh house bill 1536 and i will
recognize representative merchants thank
you mr chair
this bill basically had three components
to it
one was the issue of the pharmacist in
charge
and its legacy back to a period of time
which was a lot of independent
pharmacy owners and when there were
times the owner would own one or two
pharmacies
was to have a pharmacist be appointed as
the pharmacist in charge
take responsibility for the pharmacy and
be accountable to the board
since that time corporate america for
the most part owns most
pharmacies today we have a disconnect
between the
authority in the accountability so the
intent of this bill
in that arena was to try to correct that
imbalance and
have those who have the authority and
control the resources
weren't accountable to the board into
the state
or their responsibilities
in going forward and talking with the
board of pharmacy at the time
they felt that the language the way it
was written was probably problematic
and therefore it needed to be revised so
that was the first part of it number two
for those who are on the committee can
remember back there was a time in which
the board of pharmacy um has sort of a
i would say a heavy hand in looking at
the preparation of general products for
administration
outside of a hospital predominantly
within the physician's office space
and it caused a lot of stir and
it was changed if you will but what
happened was the law
still requires the board because it says
the board shall go into
an inspect versus it may so the intent
of the bill was to clarify that so the
board would have the authority to go in
based upon a complaint which would be
the may and not be forced to go in when
there's no reason not to go in
just because the law required them to do
it and the third
prong to it was the issue about
discipline
in certain parts of the statute for the
board
in some cases the board can either flap
you on the wrist
or throw the hammer at you and the
intent here was to give more granularity
or satisfication in the ability for the
board
to align the discipline in concert to
what the
um what the issue was so those are the
three things in talking with the
board of medicine and board of nursing
about the
issue of may versus shell they were
bringing back the issue of
not having war going at all which i
think is problematic
so we had a committee representative
mcguire was on the subcommittee with
myself
um carol i can't remember who the other
person was
but we at that point in time recognized
the wording in the bill although the
intent of it was probably fine
the wording in the bill itself had to be
worked on and revised so my
recommendation is to
look at this as future legislation the
concept makes sense but the bill itself
yeah the one of the issues is
that whenever you talk about
inspecting someone else's
facilities that is not actually
responsible to the pharmacy board
like a doctor's office they get all
huffy and say
you know it's it's my office it's my
business
but in some cases you do need
a pharmacist or someone who's familiar
with it
because there were many cases where drug
storage was incorrect
but it's going to be a very difficult
matter toward the law
such that it doesn't get the entire
again
okay your music
yes i had finished okay
representative schmidt has his hand up
representative schmidt
thank you mr chairman i i do think
as someone who is both the regular
consumer of
medications having reached the age of
the gradual self-disassembly of all my
physical faculties as well as mental uh
so i'm in pharmacies a lot
and and having served on the gel car and
this committee
for the past 14 years i have seen
this evolution of
the of the situation that representative
merchant has very accurately described
with regard to the the dichotomy that we
have now
prob um apologize for the ring
ringing telephone which i will ignore
but um
but the thing is that the the pharmacist
in charge still has
all the responsibility for everything
being um kosher in
the uh in the pharmacy the word kosher
not being
a religious term in this regard but
rather everything being in order in the
pharmacy
and um and yet being a
a captive if you will of the corporate
situation
uh the um the the pharmacist has
no authority to do a lot of the things
that has been removed by the corporate
structure
uh and this is puts the pharmacist
in charge in a really many respects
untenable situation and this particular
uh aspect of it is just part of the
the circumstance so i think that future
legislation is
warranted with regard to studying
maybe we're not ready to implement
anything yet but i think we have to
study this
issue uh in order to know how to deal
with it
uh so i i do think that we're we're uh
we're headed we need to go in that
direction
thank you anyone else
all right just wanted you to know
representative scitec that i muted you
because
sorry
all right uh seeing no further
discussion
in this work session uh we will move
into the executive session
pam do i need to do roll call again for
executive session are we
good to go oh just for the votes
you just can move in without accepting
just declare it and then you can go
ahead and just
have cold calls on the actual motion
okay
so we'll move into executive session and
we will start with house bill 1367
representative mcguire yes thank you mr
chair
i movie recommended for further
legislation
representative mcguire moves future
second second who was that
now representative melvin everything
discussion
i guess i'm a little confused i thought
in the early discussion we had thought
that we didn't need this
so why would we recommend it for because
there was so there were issues
did i misunderstand the whole crux of
our conversation in the beginning
carolyn mcguire yes i think what we said
is that this bill
addresses
all professions but the issue
that we regulate a large number of
professions that
not all states do including our adjacent
states
and therefore we need to consider
this but the bill as written is
is is too broad and not
focused there but there are cases where
we have a license requirement that
someone who has been doing the same job
in say maine or massachusetts
they don't have a license and it would
be very difficult for them to come to
new hampshire
and get a license
[Music]
excuse me mr chairman
i've been reminded that substitutes
cannot second i cannot make motions or
second
and so on unfortunately that's right i
will eventually
second to represent mcguire's motion
i will second six seconds
seconds okay
back to representative mcguire anything
else to further
no when we the reason we put this
into interim study was that we agreed
it was a serious concern and
we could do something about it but
because of
the shutdown and being unable to have
meetings we haven't done
any of the work that we would have liked
to but the
problem it points out is still valid
it's still our
our scope essentially and so it's going
to need further legislation
and i think as we discussed earlier that
there are
professions out there that um
where this would work and it's this
piece of legislation is just
too broad and it would be
appropriate to have further legislation
dealing with those subjects
and representative schuett has her hand
up representative
thank you um i'm sort of rethinking
what we had talked about originally on
this
and i don't think that i want
have the committee give the impression
that we are in fact
endorsing this broad piece of
legislation
um regardless as we have said regardless
of
what the recommendation is
the statement that goes along with it
can make
clear what the committee's intent
is myself i think i would rather
see not recommended for this
specific bill but would prefer to see
future legislation and then spell out
exactly what representative mcguire was
saying that i think that would be
preferable
i see representative grota has her
actual hand up
representative i do thank you
so now i'm um
what i'm i i understand the vote to say
is that if you don't recommend it is
that you don't recommend it in principle
if you recommend it you're recommending
the principle of it
not you we're not recommending or not
recommending the bill
is that right or do i have this again do
i have this wrong
we're not recommending the bill because
if we were to recommend the bill we
wouldn't have
put an interim study so it's
we're either recommending the principles
or not recommending the principles of
the bill is that correct
that is correct and it all goes into the
wording of the
report as to the intent of the committee
going forward with legislation and the
intent of what needs to be in
future legislation so what would if you
were to recommend this
sign follow up no i'm just correct me if
i'm wrong pam on this i believe
it's all in the intent of the wording of
the report
that's correct that's correct it's it's
up to you how you want
to view the vote um
but really the the statement that you
make
is going to you know prevail and
and show exactly what your your intent
was
okay representative follow-up thank you
mr chair
so what we're saying if we recommend
is that we see that there is
a need to
um relax
i'm using that word look very very
loosely
relax um some of our previous
legislation
this bill is not the vehicle to do that
with
but perhaps in the future you would we
couldn't entertain
a bill is that what we're saying
represent mcguire that
your intent um
yes my intent is that the bill is
written is not
suitable to be passed but that
it the issue that the bill raises
is important and does need further
legislation
and i'd like to comment that if you look
at the calendars
from every other session you'll
see back back-to-back
recommendations for further legislation
and against further legislation with
almost the same wording
so i think that the actual
recommendation is kind of you
is kind of undefined and there's no
clear understanding of what it means
it's only the words that really matter
so
if you've got somebody that's willing to
make the words that everybody seems to
think ought to say
vote for the motion if you want to write
a different kind of words
then vote against
[Music]
and representative schmidt has his hand
up
representative schmidt thank you mr
chairman can you hear me okay
yes okay good um
so as we all know when i
weekend you said it in your opening
remarks the legislature cannot bind a
future legislature
with regard to anything and this is this
bill is
this bill is going to die at the end of
the session one way or the other
and so to the degree that we
recognize that there is a situation that
needs addressing
uh representative mcguire would be
completely within her rights
should she be re-elected um to file such
legislation whether we
recommend against it or for it
but i think we to the degree that the
committee recognizes
that there is a problem with regard to
certain professions
that are not licensed in other states
but
may be licensed here that
that we ought to deal with that or try
to deal with it
and accept at the same time
that this particular bill is too broad
it's not appropriate
and to the degree that our language
reflects that
uh i'm prepared to vote for the motion
and and and i think that
representative mcguire will likely
sponsor the legislation
to do it the way she
understands and we will have a shot at
it because it will come back to this
committee
the motion is recommended for future
legislation
[Music]
noting that this is not the vehicle that
we were looking for it's too broad
that will be stated in the remarks
noting that there is issues in certain
professions that should be looked at and
addressed
um that motion by representing maguire
seconded by representative
scitec and representative scitec you can
call the roll
representative show it
as noted uh representative schmidt
yes representative
representative desjardins yes
representative fellows
yes
representative fox yes
yes representative grota yes
yes representative merchant yes
representative o'brien yes
representative mcguire yes
panda city yes
representative pearson yes
yes representative melvin
yes
and the chair their votes yes
16-0 the vote of 16-0
uh the motion of recommend for future
legislation
is adopted and there is no consent
calendar on these so we don't have to
ask that question
all right the next bill up is house bill
and the chair recognizes representative
schultz for ignition
yes mr chair i um forgive me if i don't
word this perfectly but
i would recommend this bill be um
introduced for future i don't know how
you word the emotion but i
to support the bill for being presented
again with
certain changes especially a concern
over privacy
but the underlying concept of the bill
is very good
it needs to be addressed there
are cases of actual abuse at
these um at these home care
developmental disabilities facilities
and having cameras representative can i
get a
second before you go forward oh sorry
i'll second that
representative schultz recommends future
for future legislation
seconded by representative pena city now
you may speak to your motion
representative schultz
sorry about that that's okay um yeah
that there are
concerns about the sort of incidents
that would be captured by these cameras
that would hold
folks accountable so um folks wouldn't
be abused in these settings
to provide protection to
assist families and getting to the
bottom of what
some situations they've encountered with
their loved ones have
endured they would be able to figure out
what happened
hopefully keep it from happening any of
these difficult
um abusive situations
so this bill is on the right track and
we do believe it should be presented
again and
we specifically want to make sure that
concerns over privacy
are addressed in a way that makes sense
thank you representative panda city do
you want to speak to a second
thank you mr chairman um some committee
meeting definitely showed that there is
a need
um there are people that would love to
see this
it's good to hear from miss aikens about
rules have already established
certain requirements or certain
procedures for for
video surveillance it still needs to be
looked at there are still cost issues
privacy issues
that need to be addressed and i think
the best way to do that is move forward
[Music]
raise my hand quickly enough it's
representative schmidt
i just want the record to reflect in in
terms of the
actual executive lesson that we are
aware
of concerns with regard to the potential
for uh you know
harm to the uh to the funding stream as
rep
as referenced by miss aiken uh
and um so i want that to be on
on the record for uh the executive
session and our action at this time
seeing none we'll try this again uh
the motion is recommended for future
legislation made by representative
schultz
seconded by representative panda city
and when ready
representative schmidt
yes representative schultz
yes representative fox
yes yes representative grota yes
yes representative o'brien
yes representative mcguire
yes the clerk votes yes
representative penn panda city yes
representative pearson
yes representative melvin
yes and the chair their votes yes
the usual suspect 16-0 the vote of 16-0
the motion
and next one up we'll take is 15 28
house bill 15 28.
the chair recognizes representative
stewart for a motion
thank you uh in accordance with
my prime sponsors recommendation
i will move not recommended for future
legislation
not recommended for future legislation
seconded by representative schmidt
i think i heard correct
i think pretty much everything that
anybody wanted to say has been said
bill i will try and make
the statement as clear as possible that
we definitely want to see the department
go forward with this in the best
possible
means and i will state that
if we don't see that happening in 2021
that we will put forward legislation for
2022.
thank you representative schmidt do you
want to speak to your second
yes i do mr chairman thank you i think
representative walt's
remark that this is going to be a long
process to do the study
that has already been initiated and we
will have a chance to
monitor that and see whether
it's getting the kind of results that
would uh
justify not proceeding with
with additional legislation and if it is
not proceeding in that fashion
that we will have a chance in the second
term uh
in the second year of the term of the
session
to introduce such legislation
so we're i think we're good to go on
that
seeing none uh the motion on
house bill 1528 is to not recommend for
future legislation
made by representative schubert seconded
by representative schmidt
and when ready representative scientific
you can call role
okay representative show it
yes representative schmidt
yes representative schultz yes
representative desjardins yes
representative fellows yes
representative merchant
yes representative o'brien
yes yes representative mcguire
yes yes clerk votes yes representative
panda city yes yes representative
pearson
yes representative jakobovic
yes representative melvin
yes and the chair here votes yes
16-0 the vote of 16-0
and the last bill would take up today is
house bill
15 36. relative to
pharmacist in charge the inspections
regulations of prescription drugs
by pharmacy board and disciplinary
actions by the pharmacy board
and i will recognize representative
merchant
thank you mr chair um i believe the
three
fundamental issues that this bill
addresses are important and should be
done with at least discussed um but
it does also require additional
changes and modifications to the bill
itself so they can't go any further can
i get a second
so i think the concepts of the bill the
premise of the
issues raised by the bill to be
addressed by the bill
are valid and important however the
language and the bill that was proposed
is in need of revisions and i believe
future legislation will be able to
resolve
the issues and it's a possibility for
the stakeholders through
future discussion and also input from
other
factors to weigh in on the future
legislation to at that point in time
make the
bill the workplace should what it's
thank you representative schmidt would
you like to speak to a second
i thank you mr chairman so this bill
will be coming back to us
i think we can be fairly confident that
that's the case
and we will be able to see and we will
have plenty of input because we know
that
that some of the other professions are
concerned
about pharmacy board overreach and so
forth and so on
as am i um but
that these this is a profession which is
also evolving
and this uh this concept
of um of infusion and so forth is is a
procedure that is becoming ever more
commonly applied
and practiced i myself had one after
having had an
about in the hospital with a
urinary tract infection and some sepsis
so i know that this infusion thing is
extremely significant in today's medical
care
um and and this is something that also
needs to be you know all these
evolutions we need to be
[Music]
so we get the legislation right and we
will have
a good chance of having it come to a
subcommittee as well
in the next term so i think this is a
good
further discussion on house bill 1536
seeing none
the motion is to recommend for future
legislation
made by representative merchant seconded
and when ready representative scitec
sciatica can call roll
representative shoet yes
representative schmidt yes
representative schultz yes
uh representative desjardins
yes representative fellows
yes representative fox
yes representative grote
yes yes representative merchant
yes representative o'brien
yes yes representative mcguire yes
clerk votes yes representative panda
city
pearson representative pearson
yes representative jakob
yes representative
yes and the chair the chair votes yes
16-0 the vote of 16-0
the emotion passes
that's the extent of our work today i
want to thank everyone i want to
especially thank the staff
uh for doing this for us and getting
this done
uh i also want to uh
i'm hoping we'll see her before uh she
leaves town but
uh representative desjardins is not
running again um
we'll miss you we'll see you thursday
no we'll see you tomorrow yes
see you tomorrow uh anyone else in the
committee that's not
running or won't be back next year
you represent panda city you as well
that's right you know i am
i am not back next year and i did want
to take this opportunity
to say to everybody on the committee
i've done four different three different
committees and i have to put this with
the top of the list
i think it was i think all the
participants
were great worked together i think the
chairperson chairman did a wonderful job
and
i'm going to miss this i'm going to miss
everybody there thank you
thank you thank you thank you very much
mister
can i just uh make the committee aware
of something
sure um just wanted to let you all know
a person who has appeared before our
committee
before i think you're probably mostly
all familiar with the lobbyist beth
sargent before our committee she has
primarily represent independent
pharmacists
and her husband passed away on september
7th
oh my god at a very young age 59
i just wanted to make you all aware of
that
tragic i know beth extremely well
i'm so sorry to hear that i had not been
aware
all right um the only other thing i want
to bring
forward is to let everybody know some
point probably
the first half of october
i will send something out
pam i'd like to probably try and do a
committee
meeting with the new executive director
of olpc
i've received an email i know
representative schmitz received an email
on some of the changes she would like to
see going forward
i think it would be good for the
committee to sit down
and hear her plans going forward um
as an insight and so that's my plan i
hope you can all
attend and uh that way we can welcome
her and hear what
she has in store for her new position
what about an end of the year get
together jeff
we could do that as well i mean we can
do it
with mass and social distancing i was
going to say we're under the 50
requirement right so
uh could they be could they be combined
what times you mean the october meeting
and the um
the get-together yes
unfortunately or fortunately depending
on your perspective
well it's unfortunate of course all
right it will be something
that we will discuss further and we'll
let you know
where we're going from there see you all
thursday
yeah yeah thursday tomorrow
tomorrow tomorrow yeah you can go to
unh on thursday we'll be there tomorrow
yeah
representative schmidt do you want to
it's been a pleasure working with both
of you i've enjoyed it
it's uh to your point read it first time
on the committee but i think the
committee worked very well together
thank you i'm going to miss the
[Laughter]
i hope you didn't have a golf date for
tomorrow oh i did i'm gonna
all right everyone i want to thank you